[Music]
all right um Theo von and I am joined
today by our producer co-host Ari manis
hello welcome back Ari I'm good to be
here yeah to be there yeah and Matt
Weiss is he's in Australia yeah he's
very thing dude up could be good call it
why do what his wifey say that he's in
Australia
no no ex it's a good question is going
down under that's the voice of Jimi vest
would our creator and steam comedian Maz
Jobrani interesting that you said Jimmy
Beck's what stars that way you mostly
get right night on around the world as
they go Jimmy vest with Stern oh yeah
well he came to the premiere they all
came to the premiere that you had done
in 2014 and that long is I'm crazy bro
yeah I remember seeing eye dog last year
we made it 24 right you're right 2016
are like modest rather than five a lot
goes on in his life
yeah no like forever ago wow man and now
it's an amazing that was amazing to see
just just for you to bring that from
start to finish was that just
unbelievably hectic dude I'm telling you
as a stand-up you know stand-ups we work
in 15-minute intervals until you get a
headlining saying we work at an hour
interval and then it and and writing a
movie was just such a different beast
I've such respect for filmmakers because
you really first of all I don't know
stand-up comedians have less of an
attention span or what but you know we
get to go on stage on a nightly basis
stuff but with a movie you got to stick
with it as a co-writer and I started
writing the movie almost 10 years before
and we just didn't have funding so we
just kept writing writing writing and it
wasn't until right up towards the end of
it where we're close to the production
time we did a crowdfunding got a few
people that invested there's something
we have the money really we got to go I
didn't realize you crown funded that so
you made that may say all yourself
Thunder well yeah we crowdfunded
probably like a fifth of the budget once
we had that then we got investors that
came on and even when you make the movie
now you're done you go great now
festival just going to eat us up that's
Wow so then we ended up we ended up in a
festival the Austin Film Festival not
not not the South by Southwest but
awesome film festival and we won a
couple of prizes there for best comedy
and that's when I was like oh this is
this is huge and then it's just kind of
then we had to find a distributor and
we're a lower budget movie without any
big names in it and so except for you
except from wall waiting collecting
guest stars in there too and we're now
we're talking
we still lower budget you're talking at
least a million dollar budget right
we're less than a million were you
getting we're half a million but but it
had a good look our DP his name is
armando solace he really did a good job
of making it look good you learn a
little tricks like we were we had a we
had a scene at the beach and they go
well to make it look bigger
let's go above the beach and get a shot
off the cliff of the whole ocean and
then let's go into the beach we go
that's a good idea and it makes it look
bigger yeah so he did a great job and I
was I was very proud of the whole movie
matter of fact the the main villain was
John her too just passed away recently
real a nice like the bad guy in it he
passed away like a week ago or something
oh wow yeah
one of that one if that was one of his
last like possibly big garage he did
sharknado so I don't feed the sharknado
2 I didn't watch those 5 now they
justified okay yeah pretty much the same
movie right um I think they're sharks of
like like merged with a different animal
now fish is ERDs or something like ashes
or dark lizards out there I mean how I'd
have to be to work on that movie we had
one of this we had actually the star the
start late-- of the new sharknado 5 was
just in and the whole time listen I was
like man this girl is pretty hot yeah
yeah you got a number I couldn't even
hear I could not even hear a lot of us
he was saying do she's really charming
and amazing she's from Texas but I was
just kind of encumbered with some of her
beauty yeah so I think that's the trick
they have to tip you know the ladies and
they got the sharks you know so I want
to do you told me now I want to do the
movie yeah hey Theo you know what one
new month that means a new loot crate
loot crew and August's loot crate theme
is it is kingdom it is yeah kingdom I
just got mine yes I didn't open it yet
oh I didn't get mine you didn't in this
August will create you'll find items
from Legend of Zelda ooh
Adventure Time and the Lord of the Rings
so it's probably to be good alleged
Zelda I remember from growing up and
they've redone it over the years and I
think it just count with a brand new one
yeah Adventure Time I'm not even
familiar with so I guess I'll learn
about that yeah exactly
it's the Lord of the Rings everybody
knows about are you a lord of the Rings
nerd I'm not a nerd but I definitely you
know I like my lord and I like my ring
aha
it's the best surprise that you know is
coming lootcrate offers an epic range of
like pop culture items and nostalgia
items for less than 20 bucks a month
there are monthly wearables and
accessories with cult classics and your
favorite franchises if you go to loot
where yeah and get some clothes to loot
where and if you want to geek out your
pets you can try it loot pets so imagine
this having like a fun surprise box that
comes every month it's going to have
great things in it for you or for
someone you care about yeah
if you
like a kid or a family member or friend
anyone who like you just want to kind of
treat them to something neat every month
yeah they love nostalgia picked a
nostalgia that's in their in their realm
Luke where Luke great Luke pet I mean
and it's not over-the-top it's easy it's
it's for items lesson like 20 bucks yeah
and it is a great thing to get each
month so be the envy of your friends get
100% exclusive it's completely
completely exclusive crates that loot
crate comm flash allegedly enter the
code see oh yeah what are we going to
change that enter the code co2 save 10%
on any new subscription yeah that's it
loot crate calm slash allegedly into the
code Theo th EO August loot crate theme
is Kingdom and this offer expires August
19th yeah at 9 p.m. Pacific time so you
have to get in if you want the kingdom
loot crate get you look right now if
everyone that's different it's a great
surprise I promise you try it out for a
month see what you feel yes that's loot
crate calm slash allegedly code seal so
re had a question before you came in
he's like there's Mazdas Maz dislike
Jews you know yeah that was a nice
Ferrari right right but but like no I
said I think mom is Jewish no I'm not
Jewish but I I mean I was like knowing
the opposite right which is Muslim I
guess I don't know no I am today's world
in today's climate I have I mean I have
and there's a lot of Persian Jews I have
a lot of pretty Jewish friends I have
Jewish friends a Muslim I'm not really
religious because honest are very
secular I mean I I was born in Iran
right and then we left Iran at the time
of the Iranian Revolution so we fled the
Islamic Republic of Iran basically and
my family was secular even back then and
how old are you six is not so for me you
know religion other people's religion
has never been
issue for me the only time religion was
an issue is when I was in college he's
known about hot girls and I was like
sitting on a bench and this kind of
pretty girl came over started talking to
me and I was like oh what this is this
doesn't happen I was like what this is a
beautiful day and then the next thing I
know if you like have you thought about
going to church and I was like what like
yeah I haven't you know when you come
around like oh come on I think she just
kept insisting about the church and
finally I actually is funny that they
can't get rid of her I was like ah I'm
Muslim and she was yeah I'm not
religious but I thought maybe she never
even heard of that one thought maybe
she'd be like all year you know you're
not one of us but she didn't even
because I think that kind of Christian
whatever that kind of Christian is I've
been jelica or whatever they it's like a
telemarketer like they have an answer
for you so they can tell more did not
make me remember I was like a Muslim
she's like we accept every God and
you're welcomed in the Lord Jesus and I
was like yeah you know I'm good it's
like if you accepted Jesus I was like no
I didn't - you look cool it's like okay
so you like you just became this thing
if I turn your room a telemarketer and
that's aggressive that even though she
was really hot you were still trying to
get rid of her because me I would just
pretend to be Christian until I could
you know maybe take her out on a nice
night and then I'd tell her that I'm
Muslim
we'll see bro that's not that's the
problem right there is that you guys
like you that's the problem because you
fall for you're going to end up element
supposed to date and then realize you're
not only because she's going to be like
owner that I'm not that kind of girl
maybe like oh [ __ ] I wasted all this
time and bought her a coffee or whatever
you buyer oh hey yeah we got a hat maybe
you'll be like I was gonna get laid this
well then he's wasted your time yeah I'd
be happy with just a little hand-holding
maybe like yeah I don't know I mean that
might be a tough for a reach I don't
know I mean I guess there's not it does
is there any like contention between
comedians of different religions do you
feel like there's Indians I have never
seen that I mean I think I think I think
people that are angry
angry whether your comedian over here a
politician or write whatever so I'm sure
there's I don't know I'm sure if you go
to the comedy so you know Comedy Cellar
they're pretty aggressive with one
another I'm sure that at one point when
they were having a little argument there
might have been some guy who called
someone a Jew or whatever right sure
that's come out but I personally feel
like when you're in this business it's
hard to be I mean I'm sure we have
racists in this business but it's hard
to be really racist as a comedian
because we have so many different types
and you're not hanging with hanging out
with so many different them and all
really you read it's funny or not you
get the respect out of being funny or
not you're either hack or you're not I
was going to say I think I've only seen
race arguments among bad comedians right
good convenience or just funny as
haunted yes funny joke yeah yeah that's
a good that's a good point yeah I see a
lot of bad community to spend their day
just arguing on Facebook all week you
know what he used to be was when I when
I first I don't know how you became a
regular to factory but the way I did it
was I stood in line and really how you
got past the factory yeah you're the
only president ever met that guy passes
I fasted and a little bit over here does
the other story
no I um I I stood in that line I had a
day job at the time and I showed up and
I don't know I got out of work in like 2
or 3 or whatever one is stood in line
and it was interested in my first I'm
standing in that line and like you said
at Facebook now that stuff was around
this is probably like mm maybe maybe
2001 but I think is 2000 so I saw all
these guys arguing with each other some
of them about their place in line some
of them about whatever as the day went
on and I thought oh these guys all seem
to be veterans of this line therefore
they must be good comedian because they
must come here all the time
and exactly you're saying like out of 12
20 comedians perform out of 20
I was decent and there's one of the guy
who was decent the other 18 worked like
literally crazy yeah so you realize
you're like oh these guys you know
that's and that's why they're arguing
with each other yeah there's just nuts
and they're not there to put in the work
they're there to whatever belittle the
other guy because they think that will
make them better yeah it's almost it's
interesting it's almost like it's
interesting that a lot of the sign up
because they have here at the Comedy
Store to where yeah the guy signs up and
then you see like a lot of people end up
getting onstage as long as it's pot luck
they'll just randomly choose like seven
of them will literally be people that
are looking for shelter people have
water you know people that are looking
for sell their eggs somebody's you're
trying to sell her eggs like about two
months the chef here who doesn't speak
very much English I'll go up i straight
up some pimp up here once I'm given a
red outfit and then the hostess that
night whoever was like when the when the
pimp got off he brought two of his
[ __ ] with him so as the pimp got up
the hoses make fun of them and then he
yelled something they're like I you know
I see in the streets [ __ ]
real pimps go it's hard to really joke
around with the PAMP yeah you know
there's a serious business I and I don't
know I probably met him but I don't
think I knowingly of meta Pam yeah are
you sure I'm one of the guest on my
podcast as any dude offered some chick
to you and just randomly that was
probably pimp if you've had that yes
never happen to me never happen now
except for the Hong Kong happen to me in
Minnesota actually I met a couple pimps
outside of a place and how much do they
want let him say you better hold on you
a girl so he said I was like this is
good right and then it was kind of
awkward for her because she's just kind
of in the middle of that equation so you
were at in the administer were you like
at the club you know that's just a
musical venue with this kind of
rubenesque woman and I might never
really know her you know and Rabin asked
was I mean just kind of like like 1,800
sexy you know like just then you just
met her that night yeah okay matter and
the pimp was just trying to maybe pick
up you know new clientele or whatever
he's like you better hold on yo girl oh
no I thought he was doing a hard sale
like meaning like now that you got on
your arms he's trying to be like yo you
better hold on to a girl and then he was
going to start the negotiation yeah it
was bad mood the woman who attacks first
that's what yeah that's what they do it
like strip clubs when they go up buy me
a drink buy me a drink they knew that
you know okay buy your drink and then
you're like what the hell is what and
they basically are aggressive about you
know saying it's like selling upselling
right yeah I had one time in Vegas was
like 5:00 in the morning and I was
coming home from wherever I was with my
buddy and
these girls like basically popped out
from behind like a plant yeah and they
were dressed like land hos yeah I know
and she would dress like regular girls
yeah and it kind of started like like
hey guys what he goes up to and again is
one of those like
I must I must look good you know and
that quickly realized they were hookers
they were dressing regular and hiding
behind plants that were undercover
hookers no that's how they rule man
there were cops
no they're workers Oh regular hundreds
every where's the camouflage hookers
like right gonna make you think they're
regular okay okay yeah look at the blue
bag wow that's kind of hot yeah are you
tired of doing all your own work time to
expand your business
well how many to hire someone and if you
are hiring do you know where to post
your job to find the best candidate well
I can tell you that with zip recruiter
you can post your job to a hundred-plus
job site with just one click
yep they're powerful technology
efficiently matches the right people to
your job better than anyone else that's
why if recruiter is different unlike
other job sites dip recruiter doesn't
depend on candidates finding you it
finds them in fact over 80% of jobs
posted on the recruiter get a qualified
candidate in just 24 hours no juggling
emails or calls to your office simply
screen rate and manage candidates all in
one place with the differ kut'rs
easy-to-use dashboard you can find out
today why the dip recruiter has been
used by businesses of all sizes to find
the most qualified job candidates with
immediate results and right now my
listeners can post jobs on zip recruiter
for free that's right free you know how
much that is
that's nothing just go to zip recruiter
com splash allegedly that the IP are
e-d-u are ITER dot-com / allegedly yep
one more time try it for free go to zip
recruiter comm slash allegedly and find
the help for your small business that
you need the vets help check it out zip
recruiter com
a lot of escorts out there man and I'm
friends with a Vince offer who's a
ShamWow guy remember oh yeah that
accusation to get Bob just fighting a
hooker somewhere in Miami a long time
ago before she was like oh nice and
actually my brother-in-law I'm really
good pensive huh okay yeah crazy never
mentioned that yeah just you know I
don't like to brag about people I know
but some people do really fortunate
clean tables and never said a thing but
which is kind of ironic about everything
but he had his story one time a hooker
he pushed a hooker punched a hooker some
hit a hooker Miami's about 15 years ago
14 years ago well anyway one day he he
starts telling me about it and he was
like whoa I met a girl at a club at a
night club she comes back home we hook
up afterwards she's like you owe me
money
he's like I didn't know she was an
escort he goes I know that I'm not the
best looking guy but I know that people
know that I have money and I know that
I'm in Miami I know I'm at a nightclub
and this kind of thing of Nappanee will
allow it happens sometimes you know yeah
so then the girl says you owe me money
and he's like well I didn't know you
were a hooker you know if I wanted to
hook her they know what I got a hooker
yeah and then [ __ ] escalated and then
the girl bites onto his face oh [ __ ]
right and it tells him first I'm not
going to let go until you pay me so then
he literally has to like get this woman
off of his face you know yeah and then
that's when the police got called showed
up based on that story I've gotta side
with the guys a ShamWow guy yeah at
least 50 you know you gotta settle on
them there's two sides to every story
you know I want to know in here the
problem
had a cannibal hooker yeah hooker sounds
a while
yeah like [ __ ] Dom would you know what
she looks like nope I don't know what
should I bet there's pictures on the
internet though but he said that um no
after that no charges were pressed it
was just like that means I mean I got a
you know I don't I don't want to
generalize but they think shady yeah I
think if you're involved in an illegal
business even if you're not a bad person
just when you get into that arena you
become shady it's like when you get into
drug dealing you may be the best drug
dealer in the world but you surround
yourself with shady people you're going
to be a little [ __ ] like that that's
Shady
like you don't go to a party and make
somebody laugh and tell them you know
laven a good time and then go are you
you owe me my corporate fee yeah what
you have a professional comedian
corporate media speaking of shady on-off
unitless do but Maas played a robber and
the television show Malcolm in the
Middle
was that a true yeah there that is one
of my favorite shows i watch that
growing up as a child before entering
this shitty comedy business and I was
wondering when you because you were on
the first season of that show right or
one of the early first or second year
really you when you were on the show I
don't actually if I'm being honest here
remember the episode with you and um
gang it's okay though but you know I
want to be honest that's okay but I love
the show and I'm wondering when you were
on that show did you realize it was
going to be come this big hit
so I got into some role I'm doing
anything I think it was already kind of
a like a good show and at that point I
saw him a day job and I was auditioning
for a guest star so I got a guest star
part i'm malcolm in the middle' be
honest with you i didn't expect that i
went in an audition it's a couple guys
who robbed the like the pharmacy order
like a CVS that James Inc has Merrick
works for and back then he I mean it's
not like I don't have some have some
grand plan as to how my acting career
would so wasn't like I wasn't like I'm
only holding out for lead parts right
like no I'll take whatever you give me
for it so I want an audition for the
show that I would I knew was a fun show
I might have seen it a few times and
then I got this part there was just this
real weather no accident it wasn't an F
they characters just a guy robbing a
store and it was great to do and Jane
cares Merrick was super sweet and I
think they tase you like what's called
tapas show so you know again I had a day
job as a sistent in an advertising
agency where I'm making something like
I'm going to say 25 or 27 thousand
dollars for the year that's pretty good
then I get a week one that wait a minute
and then I get a week on mountain in the
middle where they give me five thousand
for a week like damn it is so yeah it
was I mean it was great you can yeah you
know I'm going there they're feeding me
lunch eat I mean come on and did you get
a meet that what's that one guy's name
from Breaking Bad Bryan Cranston you get
a many episodes with him I many scenes I
think I think he might have been on
sentence at high warp or who is the
who's the mouse who played Malcolm right
after you and Frankie noon yeah I didn't
media I would find every scene was just
me
kind of we were kind of bumbling idiot
robbers and the guy that I was with was
even dumber
we tried to do it at the Mart of the
dude part of the dumb guys yeah and I
have noticed what's funny is I have no
idea whatever happened to that guy again
like I've never seen him another robber
the other robber you know sometimes this
funny you do uh I did I was in a movie
called the interpreter was a big movies
like 80 million dollars yeah it was a
what's the name Pollak Sydney [ __ ]
was directing it Sean Penn Nicole Kidman
Catherine Keener it was a big movie and
I played a Secret Service agent in it
and it was pretty cool part to do it was
a relatively small part but as one of
the main Secret Service guys who's in
the office with Sean Penn and it was
cool to do it I was like I was excited
but then it's funny because once in a
while I watch other movies and I'm
looking I'm like what happens to that
guy who's playing with the third FBI guy
I never see him again right so the thing
is that my future my gun ever going to
get another play on how stand-up comedy
to fall back on it
their leader actors dude I couldn't do
it with him if I was just an actor I
probably would have quit by now
and when did you get into comedy so I
got into comedy I was a big fan at E
Murphy's of the kid so that's about 10
years old is when he was really getting
big and early 80 now when you watched
him were you in America yet are you
American East Asia and then any Murphy I
think is up on Sarah alive in like 80 or
81 and that's one of the time when I
heard is taped comedian I watched a
delirious and I mean he was just my hero
and I wanted to be like him but then
coming from a traditional family or
immigrant family they want you to be a
lawyer a doctor or navy engineer so my
parents really had me going another
route but I kept doing plays on the side
and I love being onstage and every
teacher I had would always tell me hey
you could do this you got you know you
got that thing about they think you were
homosexual definitely
they were like you are really good at
giving hand jobs now oh you mean my
parents yeah no no no people think ever
the teachers know oh no I don't think it
was that I don't think Morris they did
at least like swallowed that and buried
it right yeah and you know it's funny
because my I never I don't think my
parents ever went to like Oh our son is
gay I think my parents went to a lot of
immigrant cultures there is a big
emphasis on the community and what other
people think so if you have a
respectable job a respectable position
if you're you know mr. ambassador or if
your doctor this I mean those titles are
huge so I think that's what they wanted
in the air behind the you know actor
comedian singer is like somebody who is
like lower on the totem pole
they're probably doing drugs yeah you
know saying as you said maybe they're
gay I don't know but for them it was
like it's not even an option in their
mics like this is not a reputable thing
well community say write our purlins
today or so how are they now jugular
well exactly and well now they come
around but it took a while of me going
back and forth and finally you know for
me and actually because the reason I was
at that agency was because I still
wanted to have like a regular job that
would impress my family keep my family
happy
I was on her own in your comedic /
entertainment career
did your parents respect what you're
doing well what happened was so in my
mid-20s when I was that dad agency is
when I realized I was talking to this
older guy there and he was like hey
you're you know you saw me doing a play
again and he's like you're funny have
you thought about doing this I said yeah
every acting teacher ever had was
telling me should go for it go for it
and I go maybe I might try when I'm in
my 30s and this is when I was 26 and
he's like listen if yours when I was in
my 20s there was some things I wanted to
do I never got around to do yet now in
my 60s so we really want to do it do it
and it was a lightbulb moment and I went
for it and at first my deaf one my dad
had gone back to Iran because he'd lost
his money in America and he went back to
see if I could through any business with
the properties in Iran
and I was living with my mom and she was
freaking out like she was like are you
crazy like you know because you didn't
become a lawyer I was going to be
lawyers because you didn't do that you
dropped out of a ph.d program you're
going to be a professor you left that
now you want to be comedian like what
the hell is wrong with you she actually
she and my grandmother actually
suggested they go at least become a
mechanic right and I go I don't you guys
go from a lawyer to me Hannah yeah here
we go there you go and there were their
argument was listen people need
mechanics nobody needs an actor right so
their whole followers and I realized
they came from a revolution where their
lives went upside down so in their minds
when the revolution comes in America
you'll have a skill that you can take
the Argentine and fix cars being some
jackass comedian who can't tell jokes
over there right so anyway they were
very good and it wasn't until I was a
little while before I think I mean my
mom my mom was supportive but I think
once she started seeing because I kept
my data I was a pretty responsible
person I didn't go I didn't say hey I'm
out yeah and I see it actually it
actually worked out very serendipitously
because what happened was I was at the
days over the ad agency I was looking to
kind of quit I was hoping I get a job
that behaved me you know the amount that
I made in a year I could get out if I
got a big movie or something I could
make a decent amount get out so
the ad agency started losing business
they started laying off their their
employees and I got laid off and like
maybe a week later I got a commercial
and then that commercial you know I made
out of 20,000 over the year something
then I got another commercial then and
then I got Friday after the next so
things just started trickling in yeah
and at first my acting was paying for my
comedy because I do the you know
midnight or one o'clock spot at the
Congress or make 15 bucks right and give
me any money right right but if maybe
you weren't headlining at that point I
was I was lazy later in 2000 it wasn't
until the headlining really started
coming like when we did actually evil
comedy tour which was something that
Mitch t-shir originally put together I
know she put together so in 2000 Mitzi
was watching the news and there was the
latest uprising between the Palestinians
and the Israelis and she's Jewish and
she said I think there's going to be a
need for a positive voice for Middle
Easterners in the very near future this
is before September 11th she goes there
she goes I want to do a Middle Eastern
night she give me all my Middle Eastern
comedians and I was the only one here
yeah he wanted to go tonight called the
Arabian night so yeah so just so happens
she seen Ahmed Ahmed in the main room on
a specialty show so she brought him on
I've seen Aaron cater I said there's a
Palestinian dude he came on sam
Tripoli's half Armenian everyone came
together and we started doing this
Arabian Nights show like every six
months and then eventually that thing
grew to the axis of evil and once it
became actually evil and me I met an
Aaron all owned it then we started to
tour with it and start making decent
money and then once that fell apart
was when I was able to start touring on
my own and then we that's what that's
why I tell apart or Wyatt wydad axes of
view Apollo parties there was always
kind like a rock band there was always
some turmoil military cannot get along
because it can't Middle East is gay love
it really is like I hear all these
groups that like that hit not others
yeah and I was good with both of them
but there was tension between those guys
and it was sometimes it would get fixed
and we were we'd have like a honeymoon
period and then another thing would
happen and so it was constant and still
got to a point in 2007 where it was
actually just starting to take off
because we came out on Comedy Central in
2007 then we toured around the country
then we went to the Middle East and
actually did a tour in the Middle East
was important a group of American
comedians had gone to the Middle East
with his five countries and we got there
they had just played our special on a
network there so we were like rock stars
suddenly like we were we were holding
press conferences yeah it was crazy dude
lately like in Beirut they think they
got a thousand seat theater they got us
for one night sold out two three nights
two five nights of Google we did like we
keep saying like 27 sold-out shows in 30
days the king of Jordan came to our show
Oh crazy chick on them and so it's so
bad so what is that like that that a
claim there is it like is it it is just
from men are women even allowed to let
go and you know and I'm not trying to be
weird or anything but I'm just so
curious shame like there well first of
all every country is different so you go
to the United Arab Emirates where Dubai
is and they're trying to be more modern
and more open-minded they still have a
lot of rules where for example like some
couple got arrested for like making out
on the beach or something like there's
rules that are weird but there still
exist overall they're trying to be open
to Western culture so when the use shows
there you had people from all kinds of
backgrounds showing up guys girls all
mixed together get Indians you had
America expats you had all kind of
British people they had a local so that
was Dubai I'm going to Beirut Lebanon
where you have mostly Lebanese showing
up but Lebanon is also very hip and
modern and if anything even more so like
they're almost European and they're like
just go for it like they took us out
not after one of our shows to a local
club and it was like the craziest DJ
you've ever seen two girls grinding up
on the wall like making out and stuff
and I'm like what the hell is going on
here and then I was like bro this is
Wednesday which is you see Saturday I'm
like what
so it was like Lebanon it's crazy in
that way then you end up in a place like
with a kuwait kuwait there's no alcohol
allowed so there they have a little more
few more restrictions on what you can do
right like the after-party isn't some
guys house like in the basement and and
and so but but but for the most part it
was it was mixed like I've done shows in
Saudi Arabia so that's the place where
men and women don't mix and so
originally when I did shows a Saudi
Arabia this wasn't part of this tour was
another tour
there was a promoter who would do it he
had to do it in private places so you
would do a compound where a lot of
expats are living and it was like on a
tennis court so you'd have Saudi show up
as you had other people and they were
all mixed together recently there's a
prince over there who started doing
public shows and so when he does his
show that I did at one time he'll have
he has to have to this public one side
of the room is all dudes one side of the
room is all families husbands wives and
kids so you'll be like you know up joke
about your kids and the right side
laughs and all you do is just staring at
you and you do like a penis joke and the
dudes laugh and the and the side with
the families there Joyce the jaws drop
because they're like I can't believe he
fisted
wow that was pretty trippy in that way
but overall though it was an interesting
experience because we were in 2007 we
went out there we're getting so much
attention and it went really well and
ever since then now every one of those
countries has its own budding comedy
scene and you'll get comedians there
that you wouldn't expect to see like a
lot of American comedians go there
because when we first went to a lot of
these countries that said you know talk
about anything you want but no sex no
religion no politics right I was like
what am I going to talk about right but
you know we have comedians they like you
know their act might be very racy even
in America and if I've seen a few of
those guys over there and I'm asking
myself how are they getting by with the
rules that they're given but my guess is
that sometimes if I gear a big enough
star like if you're a movie star or
something let's say whatever you've done
movies that they recognize I think
they're a little more lenient over there
right and they'll let you kind of go for
it yeah
so yeah it's interesting so right when
the group was like starting to become
better known is when all the conflict
kind of reached the head and then we
just split apart Wow
but it was an and it was a natural
growth because for me it was like you're
able to go out on your on what knowledge
and my one hour right I show right and
that was the Netflix and that was my
first one was a Showtime one was called
round and friendly the one now is my
first Netflix one which is immigrant
it's the first time because the other
ones have all ended up on Netflix I mean
but this is my first original Netflix
special which is you know how now
yeah and monitor actually were brought
together by a tweet to have a like a lot
of my special satire so at the end I'm
like you know I'm saying that you know
big black women are hogging all the
wheel chairs at the airport just like
really just going in everything and then
I'm like Persian people get out you know
that's like how it closes and then it
immediately some kid tweets at us like
so funny a closest person people get out
and then now you should watch Maz
Jobrani okay how funny was this that
gets Netflix from for whatever reason
because he said because he said the
writers
that's what you say it and it said oh if
you like this helps funny was that dude
that is interesting though it's like as
you're kind of known as this Middle
Eastern comedian it's kind of a lot of
your following is that you ever because
I've seen you do comedy juice at The
Improv and kill for you no I'm mostly
white crowd whatever all the crowds do
you ever wish that you were more of a
general comedian that that didn't have
the in audience I don't consider what
the Middle Eastern comedian I'm a
comedian happens to be Middle Eastern
but also I'm very American I grew up
here right so my audience is this funny
because it depends so what happened was
originally well as personal stand-up I
don't think anybody in the like Persian
community or these other communities
really knew who I was I was here so
that's that's my material I think
crosses over because my material is me
I'm a very American experience or an
immigrant experience but it's very
American American so I was used to
performing here at The Comedy Store and
the Laugh Factory in front of just
generic odd actors yeah
and what's happened is because there's
been more and more comedians of this
these backgrounds in the recent past I
think we're starting to see more and
more people from these backgrounds
coming to shows so if you come and see
me when I tour like it became a saw me
an Irvine there's a lot of Persians and
right right come to show at Irvine
you're going to get like you know 50 60
% Persians 40 percent others because you
come to Denver and you see a show
there's like 30 Persians and there's 250
of others right so it really has become
this thing where it depends where you
see me and I and I personally love
having a mixed group like you'll see in
the special I start asking people where
you're from where you from and there's a
girl from Ukraine and there's a dude
there's a white dude and then there's
like Pakistani there's an Indian so
there's people from all over so
again I persecuted the comedy works no
matter where I mean the only way like I
would say that like if you're a little
like I was in my politics or a little
more left I think if you're a little
more left you're going to enjoy my stuff
more but then there's also people that
are so far left that they'll get
offended at some of the stuff you say
because we're in this era now where you
know if you make a rage racial comment
I'll get offended by our learning yeah
I'll get it yeah you know saying so you
know I think it's just like you just do
your thing you just keep playing your
your your voice the way you want to and
eventually people you can find you you
know what one of my like favorite things
is what I do a meet and greet so first
of all I kind of know where people know
me from so I've been doing the show on
NPR called wait wait don't tell me which
is a fake quiz show that you do every
weekend and it's got a big white
audience and a lot of older white people
so if I'm if I'm you know doing being
great afterwards and I see older white
people waiting I you know I know they're
supposed to be like wait wait don't tell
me
thank you and then and then I did Friday
after next which had like a big urban
audience so if I see like some like
Latino dude or like some black dude that
they kind of like is a little more hood
and I love them like and I'd be like
Friday after night there but the ones
that I never have no idea how they find
me I had like like Japanese or like
Chinese or like vietname like hardcore
Asian exactly not Japanese Americans all
right knees barely speak English
Mario running they're giggling and then
they come up and it is great like where
did you know idea so one other thing
that I think about an animal is I did a
TED talk you get with Ted but
all right so did a TED talk you really
knows your job you know basically look
the first one was the guy who was the
producer of that tour that we did in the
Middle East he had done a TED talk in
Dubai is like a TEDx in Dubai and the
guy who was the main Booker for the TED
Talks told him hey why don't you come to
the main TED talk in England in Oxford
do what talk about bringing comedies of
the Middle East and get one of the
comedians to come and do it talks like
stand-up show I just basic my stand-up
and turn it into a talk right and then
alpha that they did another one in Doha
Qatar and they invited me to go do that
as well so like couple of like that one
has like out of five million views
online Wow
I get like some people find me through
that so you just don't know it you just
keep doing your thing and eventually
people show up do you think it matters
these they come because I'm sure you've
probably seen at least a breadth of
things change in the past 20 years right
as you know as we all kind of have but
in your time in comedy do you think it
matters what you do now where you come
from now or what was part of it all is
about like people ask me like what are
you write about is what interests me
right so it's what interests you so I
you know first of all wasn't all when I
go on stage I go on from Iran if there's
jokes coming off of that I kind of need
to say that if I were a black guy you
know a black guy I don't even say I'm a
black guy right right I could think yeah
I could think he's Latino I could think
he's a Native American whatever I just
yeah yeah grew up near like a fire yeah
you think a lot of guys a great famine
yeah so but but you know you used to
like some women you want to tell some of
your story you kind of go this one
fromit is where is where I grew up
right I think that kind of can be part
of it it's not that it's important
necessary I've done assets where I've
intentionally said I'm not even gonna
mention my backgrounds gonna do the set
and that's going well and we have jokes
about other stuff right fine know that
these days I mean do you like like maybe
15 years ago you've been like oh I'm not
going to do that I'm not going to do
that because I want to stay in this
certain Lane whereas these days now
it doesn't even matter what you do
anymore you're just going to find your
audience we have Jennifer Aniston coming
back to television you have celebrities
are doing commercials now that they
never would have done 20 years ago when
I was growing up you know I never you
know I never strategized like that I
always was like I'm talking about what I
think is funny to me and I'm talking
about what I think my experience is so
originally when I first started to a
stand-up comedy class Yammy character on
I took Judy Carter oh hey go oh I'd be
taking a stand-up comedy class until
April ready already of economic re later
I'm here so when I took that class you
know one of the things you know they
teach you they talk about you and like
I'll break it down who are you who are
you so really for me it was like growing
up Iranian in America is hard okay write
jokes around that right so I started
doing that and then a lot of times early
on it was like I'm a running at this I'm
around that but then eventually I
realized some of those experiences are
not just a roni experiences their
immigrant experiences I remember I was
doing a joke about how my grandmother
used to hide her money in her bra
and Isis The Laugh Factory there's a
couple of Mexican girls in the audience
they were laughing at the joke and I was
like oh [ __ ] they're Mexican grandmother
puts her money in her bra well and so
that made me then refer to like
immigrants do you know this is my
immigrant experience oh that's
interesting that doesn't I don't think
that isolate anyone who is not an
immigrant because it's all about how you
paint the picture so if you say you know
I come from an immigrant background this
is what it's like over blah blah like
for example I'm doing a bid now where I
say I say that I talk about my kids and
I talked about how I keep going to their
school events and I was at one of their
school events and I realized that my
parents never came to my school events
you know I was born in Iran and I'm an
immigrant I go in your name again you
don't want your parents to come to your
school event because whenever compared
with school events they out you right
looks like they walk in there like hello
we got em shut up so the point is you
know by painting that pictures you're
taking a second to paint the picture as
opposed to going like I can't assume
like I can't go into the room and be
like you know you know what does my have
an immigrant parents right you know
you're embarrassed by them right and now
the white audience is going no I don't
know I didn't have any your parents you
know you're not telling them about your
story you're saying so I don't I don't
ever
I've never strategize I said I need to
talk about this I need to talk about
that
right I mean I guess once in a while
there's been jokes I've tried that I
felt that maybe is not even like it's
kind of not in my voice and point of
view I've tried it since I've felt my
audience like kind of tense up and maybe
I've gone like okay that's that that
joke is too racy for my standard
audience right they come to my tours but
like I still do it at midnight at the
Comedy Store
yeah I'm saying right so I can save it
till then yeah time and a place do you
embarrass your kids when you go to their
events I don't think I do this does to a
dissolution of the Cuban they're six and
tender stuff that you have one that you
love more than the other absolutely and
he knows it
it does now beautiful talking about some
of your premier wife is beautiful is it
still your wife right yeah she's my wife
she's Indian yeah
so they got her looks and she's and the
kids actually might my daughter six my
son is nine and they're still that age
is very cute they have a thing is called
Koo Pathan where they get the kids to
come out they run in circles around the
gym and then the shoot baskets so
there's those that age or they're like
running by you and they're waving and
they're like aww and they want to see
their parents
err and actually this was interesting so
the who Pathan the kids do the shooting
and then the parents get to shoot and I
know I know in all honesty I still don't
know how they make money now because
when I was a kid you would say hey for
every shot I'm going to get five bucks
or $1 whatever it is now the kids to
shoot and then the parents donate summer
I don't know I don't know if that's part
of like nobody loses kind of a mentality
but I'm like we just make them oh yes
now there's no K that's like I've raised
the most money yeah yeah well I think we
should bring that back but anyway that's
besides the point what yeah it is say
afterwards actually this is what this is
one of the ways they made money you pay
like I know 20 bucks and you get to then
shoot its first day it's a layup I'm
going to free throw then at the top of
the key and then you go to the halfway
you know half-court and you shoot and
each one gets a certain number of points
and obviously if you make that
half-court shot if you make all the
shots including a half-court shot
you're usually like this is like one guy
maybe an ties to do that and then they
win some like prize that a parent
donated it's kind of funny because my
son when he first started going to
school he must have been like I don't
know three or four forget but he was at
that age I think we're to him still his
father was Superman right and like I
could do no wrong and I remember
watching him watch me shoot and I think
he was so proud and I went up and I
think I might hit like the layup
maybe the free throw and then after that
I miss I miss the I miss everything from
there on yeah I remember seeing a look
of disappointment it's like wait a
minute it was almost like dude I told
all my friends that you're the best
basketball player and you can't make
this so disappointed flash-forward like
two three years later I'm sitting there
you know make the shot make the shot a
half-court shot go for it
BAM you know my son lit up like my god
like she just I mean he was so excited
and then he was this darkest all the
other kids thought the whole day the
kids were like does be my you know you
said
and in the heart of all that is my wife
meanwhile when I make that shot every
everyone thought it was the cat turn
around my wife said some conversation
with some lady know what they were
talking about you nobody knows what
they're talking about
God well that's the worst thing if your
kid told you that he wanted to be a
comedian would you be okay with that
absolutely I'm coming from the
background where my parents pushed me
away from doing what I love doing I'm a
hundred percent and it would them do
whatever they want and it really is like
you know I long as they're passionate or
they want to put in the time and the
effort I'm down like this guy I met this
other dad recently he was telling me he
goes the son wants to play baseball and
he said I told him and I think it's nuns
in high school he said I told them as
long as you're the one waking me up I'll
get up at 4:00 in the morning and play
catch with you but I don't want to be
the one waking you up right now that's a
good statement right yeah yeah they
gotta have self-discipline do you do you
consider yourself a successful comedian
yeah I do it's funny I heard a Dahmer
heiress say once I mean he's broken it
down a few times where he goes there's
only I don't know a few hundred or
several hundred comedians who are
touring and making a living doing it
yeah and he goes think about there's
like 700 professional baseball players
there's probably the fewer comedians
making a good living do a stand-up
comedy yeah and so for me really it was
like at a certain point yeah I feel very
I'm not religious or any but I feel
blessed in a way that I can do this I
really love doing what I do I haven't
had a day where I was regretting driving
to work you know I mean the travel is
hard now just because you have a family
and all this stuff but but I love it I
mean I get paid and and you know to do
what we love yeah you know we want we
have I mean I
no complaints at all I just I hope I can
like part of the little bit of anxiety I
have in the back of my mind is like when
will I stop being relevant when will I
look in the audience and it's a bunch of
20 year olds and I'm fifty or six men
will you be argot Hamilton well when I
wobble you don't give it no he's here so
buddy oh yeah does like you know topical
stuff yeah yeah but I'll give you there
was this other lady I forget her name
but she was in the Comedy Store maybe I
don't know I'm gonna guess five six
years ago doing like Cher and then doing
I don't know like what I was like real
like old-time impressions and she had
been a comedian who was around in the
early 80s Wow when those were
appropriate right but now she's still
doing Bill turn Sharon is sad I was
watching my god I go cheese is like this
is she aware of this yeah you know
saying yeah they're probably just she's
too scared shiny things and uh maybe
she's really she's ears yeah maybe she
just stopped evolving in a certain point
or she got busy she had children who
knows
I thought Jamie Kennedy one night this
years ago well I think she's one of the
funniest to like listen like I tell
stories around him forever but he was
doing like a Ozzy Osbourne impersonation
but like way after he should have been
doing it yeah and I think he kind of
realized as he was doing it like this is
the last time I'm different but it just
uh it was just one of those moments that
made me think like wow like yeah you
have to evolve well but I had at least
funny because like i-i've had bits where
I go okay I want to reference that event
how do I represent event and make it
somewhat evergreen or you know a righty
right or
learn I learned the difficulty some of
this I was trying to do a whole bit
about how I can't wait some of my 70s
because I was like what's your seventies
he's doing a value Wong nobody cares but
you know like in the 20s you carry like
20 you don't care what they're like 30
see your mortgage and waited it but by
70s I started giving a list of people
and the things they were doing and one
of the people I brought up was Marlon
Brando who if I don't if you were sought
but there was an interview he did with
Larry King towards the end of his life
he was probably like in his early 80s or
late 70s and Larry King's asking him all
kinds of questions and the whole time it
was this supposed to be this like
hard-hitting interview and Marlon Brando
the whole time kept trying to get Larry
came to eat cookies mmm the whole time
he's just getting a glare cookies have a
cookie and it became the simple thing
and it was so funny to know Sarah alive
they had John Travolta who was a guest
play Brando feeding them cookies there's
plenty no dick I talked about Brando
looked at me on it again this was the
Laugh Factory
listen honey otama Brando and I see this
guy who looks to me like he should know
Marlon Brando and look lady was like it
is late 20s or something and looking to
me with like a blank stare and I go you
know Marlon Brando right he goes no I
was like how older he's like 24
something I was like oh my god there's a
generation right it doesn't even know
more yeah Rand oh yeah that's scary [ __ ]
let's get a vote
yeah and then because of that you have
to force yourself to watch the dumbs New
Wave YouTube stars I don't have to watch
the YouTube stars so I can know if they
yes true huh it's interesting it's like
and how do you stand how do you Dave
like in the know now when in the no has
gotten we're finding sources for in the
know has gotten so exponential like it
used to be when I was in high school in
college you came home he watched MTV
right like that was the only place to
get cool like yeah watched it
you watched it was so cool that if you
told people you wash other things it
wasn't cool like I would lie to my
friends yeah I'd be like I just watch
MTV
yeah I wasn't watching live Emeril Damon
you know crazy dude you don't watch the
Disney Channel that's for day yeah it
forget she get children or animal you
know really really humane even though I
did I watched the Disney Channel yeah -
man I stood dance around in my living
room a lot okay let's put the TV on
sound [ __ ] Daniel yeah you're right
you know you know he's done actually
kind of a good job of kind of aging I
think it's like I've seen Seinfeld do
his bits on The Late shows he still is
talking about things that are relevant
whether it's and its point of view is
that interesting point of view so you
can be me Carlin did it you can be you
can get older right and do jokes that
make fun of younger people and younger
people still can laugh as long as you're
in that conversation so like for example
I get busy or take on on the YouTube
stars like if you have if you have
people that like that as a youtube star
named I don't know Bumbo or whatever his
name is
here in a room and these guys have no
bumbo and you're an older dude making
fun of bumbo they're going to love
hearing you talk about bumbles yeah I'm
saying yeah here in that take man well I
noticed you just watching you man I
noticed that I think you do a really
good take on on fatherhood you know and
stuff like that and so I really enjoy
listening to it thanks yeah it's funny
it seems like yeah so if any of those
concerns ever start to you know rat on
your head I wouldn't let them flare up
yet well you know I always I always use
the example of Erik Estrada cuz I go
there was a time when Erik Estrada was
on chips and he was probably looking
around going like I am the [ __ ]
this thing is going to last forever
whatever a year later he's on telenovela
Telemundo only knows hi I'm Erik Estrada
yeah did you say filling irons now
homeless right I know that really
handsome that look good you wouldn't
know if it is an artist right it was a
show called chips remember the movie
chips that just came out on with based
on TV show and Erik Estrada with the
Latino tune in there and our but hunky
look and do that but he just you know
the show was a hit probably what late
seventies early eighties for a minute
but again it's just this thing of I
think I think as long as you stay in the
game you keep writing stuff or you write
you have a perspective that people can
relate to and if you sincere like a lot
I mean all my stuff I know your stuff to
it all comes out of real life yeah so
people if you can you know I think we
become storytellers so if you can keep
it sincere and then find punchlines
because that's where I think that's
where the comedian comes and you got to
take that real thing and find a
punchline in it even if that punchline
didn't happen you got to add it to it so
that you didn't embellish the truth I
mean yeah if you can't just be like oh
yeah what's the Starbucks and I order
the wrong coffee yeah and then I left
alright well what what else happened in
the middle right I mean yeah I get
molested yes you got some something yeah
yeah like I agree it's um I don't know
it's constantly it constantly is
interesting to me how this career
evolves and I'll and I'll say this is
that once you
there were times where I'm like I can't
make any more material I mean I could
but I know what I have I can put
somewhere it's almost like I'm just
waiting for a place to put it and then
once you have an opportunity to do a
special or to do a half-hour do then
it's like your brain almost then can you
switch into another gear absolutely it's
amazing one of the best feelings is when
you do have a special and then you start
touring afterwards and people come see
you and you're like oh wow I need a new
material because I've seen the special
and then after six months to a year of
touring you start going oh wow that bit
that was a killer on the special I'm not
even doing it anymore oh I'm not doing
that with you and it's such a good
feeling like oh somehow authentically
just just organically a whole new hour
came about
and that's because you just keep talking
about your life in your experiences and
just end just riffing and riffing it is
a good feeling good yeah I mean it makes
you feel that then is the first time I
ever felt like I was in the right job
that was in the right place I mean I
thought I wished it a lot of times and I
knew I felt like I was entertaining
people but until that happened why
didn't have faith really a lot of times
that I would come up with new stuff yeah
and then to have new stuff to know that
you're like brain or your spirit or the
powers that be in the universe are on
board with whatever you're trying to
stay a part of yeah man that was really
really relaxing although for you to be
forced to write new stuff you're saying
if you do if you put it out there on
your special then you have to you have
to come up with new stuff yeah I was
afraid ago I think afraid that I would
never have anything up but just that my
I wouldn't maybe I didn't have enough
experience it wasn't interesting enough
but that's also why that's also why
these nights when you show up and
there's eight people or or if I could I
have a meal and new material and I where
the people are forced to do new material
yeah but those are great nice because
then you end up ripping something you
thought you know your subconscious is
working on it oh yeah yeah it's tricky
to turkey time man well you can catch on
you can catch a lot of mother's views
and and the humorous views on immigrant
and they can catch also Jimmy rest food
yeah they can find it on yeah it's on
Isis Jimmy that's what it's like the
word westwood but yeah v VF t vo the
Jimmy vets with American Hero I describe
it as like the Persian Pink Panther it's
a slapstick comedy and it's on iTunes
it's and Bob's we've got a podcast thank
you
anyone absolutely we stop doing anything
but well you could go listen to the old
episodes and check out the old episodes
of minivan men and we'll we'll add
Mazdas social media as well and it's
just what monster brawny Hat Maz Jobrani
cool man well we appreciate you so much
for coming in a fellow's time with us we
have to finish up this game now where do
we at right now it looks like already's
got to and deals got three okay cool so
we need well last round 30 seconds we
each have 30 seconds to do what what are
we going to explain there are many
capitals of middle-eastern countries as
you can all right I think I'm gonna do a
little meat song for Thea exactly okay
you want to go first alright what if
what if I don't know any well then
you'll will know it is that one yeah
Cairo was nice is that one that was
Cairo I knew that one okay what about
so ha Oh matters now on yeah but that
one uh a jerusalem that'll work yeah
summers it's a capital of the bible dude
yeah I think I'm pretty sure that the
note of the embassy Jerusalem of Israel
would if you don't know we have to have
come I'm right tel aviv might have been
but okay tell me the bigger city but I
think Jerusalem is the cap is the
capital the Holy Land
well we want to say that yeah they send
you a message and tell you yeah yeah
okay I'll go with Addis Ababa
you made a name I know that I'm not a
real life you'll be right yeah yeah
that's an Africa yep nice but it's a low
now you just start in your capital T
Baba good one yeah if we could just name
capital the countries that make things a
lot easier
that's right now in return I'm going
with that but anyway we gave you your
risk level give it up thank you George
Dubai no the cow is out of the United
Arab Emirates is actually Abu Dhabi
roulette I would have let your wives got
an indoor place where you can go
snowboarding that's predict oh yeah
that's true yes yeah there isn't kind of
the capital these Millennials man yeah
yeah so I think that gives me the wind
yeah you beat me last time you guess
yeah yeah okay
it was a good game you know what it just
goes to show I need to educate myself on
capitals of Middle Eastern countries
because I I was surprised I got one an
athlete it's not before we leave and
have somebody write up something let's
just this is Google capital of Israel
and we get that real quickly I can't
believe they even knows it sorry I know
I went on birthright laughing Wow birth
wrong oh they didn't listen huh you know
I just wanted to pre-trip my define two
kids Graham oh yeah yeah I'm really good
in find Ari at Ari MANET AR ima and n is
perfect I me at do Vaughn would uh you
have any upcoming day see people come
check out applause yeah I'm going to be
in in Glendale Jerusalem called stars on
brand in August I'm also doing a
fundraiser for tree people with an
outdoor show for these native wnated
like nature it's like a nature walk up
here in Beverly Hills and then I've got
I'm going to do Doha Qatar well in
September and I'm doing the ribbon in
private October all of it at Moz Rabbani
calm Maz Jobrani calm awesome and thank
you so much for joining us hey thanks
for having me man this was this was a
fun conversation it was nice you enjoyed
it thank you so much for allegedly we'll
see you next week
you
[Music]